NOAH FALSTEIN: OK.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to I/O 2016.
Did people enjoy the keynote?
Yeah?
All right.
A lot of great stuff
there, and hopefully we'll
be segueing into
interesting ways
to use some of what you saw.
We're going to be using the
Spaces app to collect comments
and questions so that
we can do that online
and save a little
time, so we don't
have to do the Q&A here live.
So if you haven't already
gotten an update about that,
please look it up.
It should be connected to
your I/O app, I believe.
And I think there are supposed
to be some signs describing
how to use it.
But let's just move on.
I'm Noah Falstein.
I'm Chief Game Designer
here at Google.
We've got a lot of great
software, hardware, services
that are really great
for game developers
that we're going to be
showing you this year.
And this is a great
place to start.
We wanted to have an
orientation early at I/O
so that we could point you to
some of the other cool talks
and also tell you about
some of the cool stuff--
as well as make some of
our own announcements here.
So I'm going to be
starting, and then I'm
going to pass it on to
Ben Frenkel here, who's
lead PM for our Google
Play Game Services.
And we're going to finish
up with Ina Fuchs, who
is with YouTube
Gaming, and they'll
talk to you a little bit about
each of their own specialties.
But first, I'm just
curious-- how many of you
are here at I/O
for the first time?
OK.
Quite a few.
Actually, I think this
is the first I/O where
we have a majority
of returning people,
but it looks like we got
a lot of new faces here.
And how many people here
are actively involved
in the games industry,
one way or another?
OK, pretty much what I expected.
So a lot of great stuff for you.
And before I jump into
some of the new stuff,
let me put it into
perspective a bit.
This is actually a computer game
I wrote 40 years ago this year.
The code's on the left, and the
actual game input and output
is on the right.
At that point, when we
were doing computer games,
we basically had sort of
glorified electric typewriters,
and that was our
input and output.
On this particular game, you
had a list of numerical commands
you would type in.
Just a year or two
after that came out,
I saw my first
video screen and got
to code with something
that actually controlled
the video on the screen.
And it was a revelation for me.
And of course, right around that
time, as video and computers
were coming together, it made
some of the first video games
possible.
And those kinds of
combinations, we've
actually become
kind of used to it.
But every few years there's
some new dramatic mix
of new technologies
that can come together
in these great ways.
For example, we had CD-ROMs
and a higher color resolution
that enabled the kind
of modern graphics
that we're used to now.
Or modems and
server-based architecture
that made MMOs and a lot of
the online games possible.
And more recently,
we have smartphones
that are putting those
games right in our pocket
and connecting us with
everybody else in the world.
And those are just
a few examples.
The games industry now is
bigger than it's ever been.
This is a picture of the GDC up
in San Francisco from a Google
session there this year.
We had more people there,
I think, than even fit
into this room.
But right in this
room alone, we've
got almost double
the amount of people
that were at the
first Game Developers
Conference I went to, the entire
conference, back 30 years ago.
The games industry has grown
200-fold since then-- sorry,
the GDC has grown 200-fold since
then-- and with good reason.
Because there are all these
wonderful new technologies--
platforms beyond just the kind
of computers and the dedicated
consoles that we're
used to, but of course,
we've seen browser-based social
gaming, downloadable games,
a lot of indie games coming
that way, and of course,
mobile games of all types.
In the last couple
of years, we've
now started to look at
virtual reality and wearables.
So it's given us all sorts
of wonderful opportunities.
And here at Google, we
make all sorts of hardware,
software, and
services that help you
develop games, grow
your audiences,
and earn some profits.
So today, as we're talking
about some of those things,
and in the next few days as
you hear from our other groups,
I hope you think
about the advantages
that you get when you combine
some of those services
together to explore new areas--
just as those examples I
mentioned, in the past, of
new things coming together
like that-- to see
what kind of new games,
or even new entire types of
games, that you can create.
And the practical reasons for
the experimenting with this--
there are a lot of
payoffs for you.
It's really, I think, like going
through a secluded mountain
pass.
Maybe there'll be a dead
end on the other side.
Maybe it'll open up
into a fertile valley.
Maybe there's an entire new
continent of possibility.
The smartphone games,
when they came out,
are a whole new continent.
It's just amazing how
big that's gotten.
And I think that we have some
really great possibilities
coming up in those areas too.
One of the reasons
for doing that is,
if you combine some new exciting
thing, like virtual reality,
with something as big as the
billion-plus Android smartphone
users, and make a
game that works well
in both of those
fields, then you've
got something that has
the appeal and the press
attention of virtual
reality, but the huge market
of the existing
smartphones out there.
And it's not easy to
do that sort of thing,
but it's certainly
possible, and the payoff
is really worthwhile.
So that's just using some
existing technologies.
Let's consider some of the
new ones that are being
shown in the next few days.
There's a lot for you to
see in these next few days,
so I've made a couple
of slides here.
And this doesn't
include all of the talks
that I think will be of
interest to game developers,
but I tried to cull
some of the ones
that I think you'd
find interesting.
This first page is
some of the upcoming
talks about virtual reality, and
our Project Tango devices that
are quite exciting.
It's not an exhaustive list, and
some sessions may move around
at the last minute, so please
check your apps and the signs
to make sure that everything's
in the right time and place.
And there's a lot going on
with the game development
and distribution side
of things as well.
Firebase is something
you should look
into-- it's a great
way to leverage
the Google advantage that
combines our back-end services
seamlessly in your game.
And then tomorrow
and Friday, there's
some more interesting talks.
You might want to look into
things like our Android N
discussions, or some of the
Firebase fundamentals, or AdMob
and how you could use that
to monetize your games.
But let me make a few
specific announcements
that you may be hearing about
in some other places as well.
First, I'm really
happy to be able to be
making the first announcement
of the Donation API.
In the words of the developers,
what if gamers everywhere
could save the real world,
right from within your app,
powered by Google?
This is the Donation API.
It's made for gamers
and generosity.
And it uses
everything that we've
learned that users
like when they donate.
It's got in-app donations,
automatic payment
processing and billing.
There are no fees and no spam.
And it has the ability
for you, the developer,
to search and support
any US-based nonprofit.
It's brought to you by the same
group, the Social Good group,
that has powered donations
for Google.org and the refugee
crisis.
And the newly launched donation
cards on YouTube-- and I've
got some cards
describing this that I'll
put out and back later for
people to take as they leave.
Very exciting stuff.
I'm really happy to be
part of a company that's
thinking not only of
entertaining people
but helping them
at the same time.
Next, let me suggest
that you check out
our App Ads for Games.
Making games fun is really
essential to success,
and so is identifying
which customers
are best for your game.
So take a look at
App Ads for Games
to see how you can use powerful
signals from Search, YouTube,
and the Play Store to find the
best players for your games.
And then finally,
earlier this year, we
announced our app
streaming service,
and that will be described
on Stage 6 later today.
This is somewhat different
than the instant apps that
were announced at the keynote.
They have similar
functions, but they're
used for different things,
and the app streaming people
are great for letting
people try out games
by streaming them online without
actually having to download
the app onto your device.
It works pretty much like
videos are streamed on YouTube.
And it lets a
player try your game
without having to first
download it, which obviously
can be a big advantage to
getting them up and running
quickly.
OK, so let's think about
how some of those advantages
can boost your games and
bring them to the next level.
So here, while you're at I/O,
you'll be learning about some
of the other tools we have
available to developers.
And I'm urging you
to really think
about how you'd combine
them, because as I've
been saying, if you bring
them together in new ways,
it can really help you launch
new creative adventures that
draw on a really diverse
palette and increase
your chances to both get
noticed and reach new heights.
So let me give you a
few thought experiments
to show you the kinds of
things I mean, to get started.
What if you had a game about
exploring the universe that
was played by thousands who
were in a single [? shard ?]
together?
You'd want to have
complex calculations,
and that could be done
with Google Cloud Platform.
But the players could
view it on their phones
or use our Cast Services
that you can find out
about here, to Cast it
on through their TVs,
so that they can actually
see their televisions
with a starscape and pick
out their next destination
that way.
Or you might have
heard-- I'm curious
how many people have seen
our Chrome experiment game,
Lightsaber Escape?
OK, a fair number of you.
Great.
I thought that was a
really exciting way
of showing the advantage
of combining what
we can do with Chrome with
what you can do with your phone
to control a lightsaber
on the screen.
But it uses, as most
phones do, three degrees
of freedom in orientation.
Imagine using one of our
Project Tango devices,
or one of the new
phones that Lenovo
will be making later this
year, so that as you're
using your lightsaber
to deflect bolts,
it's not just seeing
which orientation it's in,
but you can move it side
to side, up and down,
and much like they
do in the movies,
send those blaster bolts
back at the Stormtroopers.
I think that might open
up a whole new type
of action-adventure game, where
you're controlling what you're
seeing on your computer
screen with your phone,
so that can be a great
interface for you.
And finally, I'll
suggest TensorFlow, which
has been getting a lot of news.
And consider how that
open-source machine-learning
tool might be used in
conjunction with something
like Google Earth to create
a new kind of game that
fused alternate-reality gaming
with massively multiplayer
games.
Imagine, for example, that you
have a world-spanning game that
has procedurally generated
objectives all across Google
Earth, so that TensorFlow
and machine learning
can help learn each
player's preferences
and make objectives that are
local to where they are and yet
fit into the kind
of world information
that you can pull in
with our services.
So those are just
a few suggestions.
As you listen to
Ben and Ina next,
and as you go out for the
next two and a half days
and hear about the
other game talks,
I'd like you to consider
how you might want
to use some of those services.
Any of the ones that
have been mentioned,
or new ones that we may not
have even thought of that
can be used by gamers--
that's happening all the time.
Go out there, create some
groundbreaking new games,
or supercharge your
existing games.
And speaking of
supercharging, I'm
going to turn it over now to Ben
Frenkel, PM of our Google Play
Game Services group,
to tell you more
about that
multi-powered service.
Thank you.
BEN FRENKEL: Thank you,
Noah, for the intro.
Hi.
I'm Ben Frenkel.
I'm a Product Manager
on the Play Games team.
And our mission is
to provide developers
the tools and services they
need to create great games--
and make money while
they're doing it too.
Very important component.
And we launched Play Game
Services three years ago
at this event, at I/O, and we
launched with just the basics.
We had achievements,
we had leaderboards,
we had a multiplayer stack,
we had a Cloud Save solution.
And since then, we've become
the fastest-growing game network
ever.
Today, hundreds of
millions of users sign
in to Play Game
Services every month,
and 50% at the top 500 games
on Play are integrated.
But since then, since
the initial launch
and over the years,
the needs of developers
have substantially evolved.
And we've had to
evolve along with them.
And Play Game
Services has expanded
to include advanced features,
like video recording,
live operations, and a healthy
dose of predictive analytics.
And slide-- there we go.
So before I go into the specific
features and case studies
that I want to
talk about today, I
thought it would be useful to
take a step back and provide
some context for
what we're trying
to do through the lens of
the game development process.
So to start up on
the left here--
and I can barely see things
because of the awkward angle
here-- but starting
off on the left,
a typical game will
start off with something
like a brainstorming session.
I've heard a lot
of game developers
have a game jam, where people
vote on whatever concept
they think is the best.
For some, maybe,
it's a eureka moment
they have in the
bathtub-- though
for me, personally, I
prefer mine in the shower.
And once you've locked
in on an amazing idea,
it's time to take it one step
further with a prototype.
And after you've exhausted
your most expedient testing
options, like your coworkers,
your friends, your family,
maybe a distant
cousin somewhere,
you need to expand your audience
by launching a beta program,
or soft-launching your game.
And after iterating
awhile, and you're
confident your game is awesome,
it has a chance to monetize,
well, you're ready
to launch and promote
your game to the public.
Hooray, right?
But these days,
launching your game
is just the start of the
journey for a game developer.
You need to continue to
invest in acquiring new users,
and you have to
retain those users
by keeping your
community engaged,
tailoring and tuning your
content to different player
segments, and
running live events.
Those are all very
important components.
But today I'm going to
focus on just three things
that Play, and Play combined
with other Google products,
are doing to drive game
developers' success.
First, we're going
to talk about how
we can help you find the right
users at each stage of the game
development process.
Then we'll cover how we can help
you tailor and tune your game
to different player segments.
And lastly, we'll talk
about how we can help you
harness the creativity
and enthusiasm
of your gaming community to
to deepen player engagement.
So let's start off
with how Play can
help you find the right users.
This is a very important part
for everybody's business.
So at this year's I/O, we're
introducing the Early Access
section to the Play Store.
And as I mentioned
earlier, once you've
built your initial prototype
and have iterated a bit,
it's important to get feedback
from the largest audience
possible before you
launch your game publicly.
And that's what the Early
Access section is for.
Early Access will
feature exciting games
that are still in development,
so that early adopters
and influencers are able to
discover and try out your game.
And importantly, it also
gives them an opportunity
to give you private feedback.
This is the perfect way to
experiment and fine-tune
your game before it's finally
released to everybody.
So when you're finally
ready to launch,
you'll need to promote
your game and find a way
to drive installs.
And for those of you who
are indie developers,
you'll be excited
to hear that we've
added a new way to highlight
you and your games in the Indie
Corner collection
on the Play Store
that we launched earlier
this year at GDC.
The Indie Corner is
dedicated to highlighting
truly amazing and unique
games that users love.
And here's how
the program works.
So first, you have
to make a great game.
It all starts there.
And then you need
to submit your game
to participate in the Indie
Corner program at this URL
that you can see on the
left-hand side of the screen
there-- I guess
your right, sorry.
Your right-hand side.
And it's
g.co/indiecornersubmission.
And from there, a
panel selects games
for featuring in the
Indie Corner collection.
It's simple.
However, there's more to
the Indie Corner program
than just the featuring, though
that's obviously a big benefit.
It also serves as a way for
us to have the opportunity
to help indie developers
understand and improve
their game performance.
And I'll walk you
through an example
of something we did with a
partner of ours, Springloaded.
So when we started
working with Springloaded,
they had just soft-launched
their game, Last Vikings.
And they gave us an early build,
and we tested it extensively,
and we wrote up a detailed
analysis of some things they
could do to improve the
game, how they could best
integrate Play Game
Services, and some
tweaks they could make
to improve monetization
and retention.
Then Springloaded
implemented every single one
of our recommendations.
It was extremely impressive to
see it all come together really
nicely, and the results for
them have been phenomenal.
So after they made a few tweaks
here and there to their game,
they were able to double
average revenue per paying user
and make huge
improvements to retention.
They in fact doubled
their day seven retention
on the back of the work
that we did with them.
And in James
Bernard's own words,
the Indie Corner program
has been invaluable to us
in helping us believe
that as a small indie
we can actually
make it on our own.
It has been a transformative
experience for them.
And hopefully you'll
all be excited to hear,
tomorrow the Indie
Corner collection
will be live on the store.
So don't forget
to check that out.
So let's say you've-- assume
for a moment that you found
the right users.
Now you'll want to keep them
coming back to your game
by turning it into an ongoing
service you deliver to players.
A very important
piece of that is
being able to dynamically tailor
content to different player
segments.
And in this case
study, what we'll cover
is how a developer has
combined the player stats
API with AdMob's
rewarded ads to increase
ad revenue while not negatively
impacting in-app purchases.
Because that was the goal--
the original stated goal,
and they were able to
successfully do that.
So let me go through
the story here.
So developer Invent
Venture integrated
spend prediction into their
game "Galactic Empire."
It's a great game.
They used the spend prediction
to determine whether or not
to show AdMob rewarded ads.
And here's how it
works for them.
If a player is
predicted to spend,
they don't show the
rewarded ad option.
If a player is predicted
to spend-- to not spend,
sorry, they will
see rewarded ads.
And they implemented
this about a month ago.
And in the short
time since then,
they've been able to
increase ads revenue by 10%
without any negative
impact on in-app purchases.
In fact, they've seen a
slight increase in them.
And it's a great case study.
And every developer,
large or small,
can go out today and combine
the player stats API and AdMob
in this way to improve
the success of their game.
And since we launched the
player stats API last year,
we've continued to
invest in new predictions
to make the API
even more powerful.
And we're excited to
announce the launch
of two new predictions
in the coming weeks.
The first is a prediction
of how much someone
is likely to spend
in the next 28 days,
and the second is a
prediction of whether or not
someone is likely to
become a high spender.
And we couldn't be more
excited to see what
creative things
you'll end up doing
with these new predictions.
So let's turn our attention
to how Google and Play can
help you harness the
energy and creativity
of your gaming community to
deepen player engagement.
And so, one thing that
we've recently launched
is Play Games gamer
IDs and avatars.
And these are a great
way for your players
to create their own gaming
persona and express themselves.
I mean, most of
the people I know
don't really want to play
games as their real identity.
I don't want to be known as Ben
Frankel in all the potentially
strange games that I play.
And in fact, I have--
I've used the same ID.
My secret nerd
name Caldorf here,
which you can see on the screen,
since I created my Battle.net
account to play StarCraft a
really, really long time ago.
I was no longer Ben
Frankel, computer science TA
and college student.
I was the zerg-slaying
Caldorf the Conqueror.
And it was very satisfying
to carry that persona to all
of my games going forward.
And with gamer IDs, which we
launched earlier in the year,
I can in fact take this persona
with me to every game I play.
And as developers, you can
actually tap into this as well.
You can find out what a gamer
ID is when somebody signs in.
So if you have a game where you
have your equivalent of a gamer
ID or a gamer tag, you can
pre-populate that field
with the ID that I've chosen.
And that should speed up the
flow of people into your game.
So now I want to talk about
how the video recording
API and YouTube can
help developers amplify
their community's impact.
So for a bit of
background, late last year
we made it possible for users
to record their gameplay
with the Google Play Games app.
And after an extended
Early Access program,
today we are excited to announce
that in the coming weeks
the video recording API will
be available to all developers,
so that players can bring up
this video recording experience
directly from your games.
In addition, players
will also soon
have the option to Livestream
their gameplay to YouTube.
So we've seen a lot of
excitement for video recording
from the smallest developers,
all to the very largest
we have on the platform.
And more than a dozen games
during the EAP program,
the Early Access program have
already launched an integration
with the video recording API.
And they're on the store today,
so you can go check them out.
But I wanted to walk you through
one particularly powerful,
exemplary integration of
the video recording API.
And flaregames has just
such an integration
in their game, "Dawn of Steel."
And here is how it works.
So before you launch a raid and
invade another base and blow
things up, you come to
this screen on your left.
So there we go.
And on this screen you
can see that red button
that has launch right
in the middle of it.
And you click that button,
you launch the raid,
and fun ensues.
Just to the left of that
red button is a camera icon.
And if you click
that camera icon,
it brings up the video
recording overlay.
And then from that overlay,
you have all the controls
you need to mute your mic,
turn off and on the forward
facing camera, as well
as of course start
and stop the video recording.
Once a recording is complete,
you can edit the video
and upload it
directly to YouTube.
And you can see here on your
right, in this screenshot here,
that I have clipped this video a
little bit in the editing mode.
And you can also see that
we've helpfully pre-populated
the title, as well
as the description,
so that players can share
their replays faster.
In the words of
flaregames' Jon Howard,
"The video recording API
helped activate our community
by enabling players to
create a let's play style
video in a matter of minutes
with minimal effort."
And it's not just
minimal for the players.
It's actually a very
easy integration to do.
And many of the
developers we talked to
said it's taken
about a day to do it,
so that's a big
ROI for you guys.
But what particularly excited
me was how "Dawn of Steel"
incorporated the
video recording API
as a foundational element
of their global replay
competition.
And in the view of the
folks at flaregames,
the replay share function
was the perfect tool
to kick off the
global competition
and let the community
show off their skills.
That is exactly the intent
behind the video recording API,
and what we wanted
developers to do with it
to create these kind
of amazing experiences
where people can show
off their skills.
They also did a
really, really good job
of incorporating YouTube
celebrity platform
into their marketing
campaign for the competition.
And here's how it worked.
To kick off the
competition, they
worked with YouTube
celebrity MasterOv
to create a video tutorial and
how to use the video recording
feature.
It's a really
impressive video, and I
thought I would take the
opportunity to show it to you,
so cue awesome video and audio.
MASTEROV: What's up everyone?
MasterOv here with an
awesome free-to-play
mobile game, "Dawn of Steel."
With the game's replay feature,
you can save your battles
and share them with others.
To do so, simply toggle
the record button
and hit play before
battle commences.
When you've destroyed an
enemy base with your squad,
stop the recording,
check out your raid,
and share your videos with
the world, easy as that.
BEN FRENKEL: It makes me want to
record video replay right now,
but I'll wait.
So it was a really great
video, high production value,
and I think a very effective
way of driving awareness
about the competition.
And to further amplify this
corresponding marketing
campaign, they had MasterOv
announce the competition
on his MasterOv
gaming channel, which
has millions of subscribers
and is a great way
to drive awareness
about the game.
And to cap it off, when
the competition ended,
MasterOv then
announced the winner
and showed the winning
replay on his channel.
This is exactly the type of
coordinated marketing campaign
supported by video replays that
every game developer should
aspire to.
And I was blown
away when I heard
about what they were doing.
And next-- cue
next slide please.
There we go.
So to recap, Play
Games-- whoa, OK.
Now we're too far.
And we also-- you're
ruining the slides!
Back.
No, no, no, wrong way,
wrong way, wrong way.
I think you want to go to slide
38, just the-- or slide 28.
Bear with us for a moment here.
We are experiencing
technical difficulties.
And you can also see all the
things I'm saying on there.
That's super helpful.
So to recap, Play Games
and other Google services
can be combined in
powerful ways to help
you find the right users,
tailor and tune game experiences
to different player segments,
and harness the energy
and creativity of
your gaming community
to deepen player engagement.
And now I'll hand
it off to Ina, who
you've seen some sneak
preview of her slides
already, to talk
about YouTube Gaming
and how the YouTube
platform has been used
to drive developer success.
Thank you.
KATHARINA FUCHS: Thank you.
Hey, my name is Ina and I work
on the YouTube gaming team
as a partnerships manager.
So that means I manage or look
after some of our top YouTube
Gaming creators, like
MasterOv, and gaming publishers
across Europe.
And today, I'm here to tell you
about the amazing, innovative,
creative, and powerful community
that we have on YouTube Gaming,
and how you, as a developer,
can play an active part in it.
But to truly understand
the phenomenon
of gaming on YouTube, I want
to share a personal story.
So spoiler, this is
me and my brother
when we were little kids.
And I guess the
socks and the sandals
show that I was born and
raised in Germany, though.
Thanks mom and dad.
Anyhow, my older brother
and I would actually
spend hours and hours of playing
"Monkey Island" together,
which is why for me today
it's even a greater honor
to be speaking
here as Noah is one
of the co-developers
of my childhood games.
So in YouTube terms, I'm
fangirling a little bit here.
We'll take a selfie later.
So back then, it was usually
me watching my brother play,
and I was throwing in
comments here and there.
He wouldn't really pass
on the controller ever.
But also, to me he was just
the greatest "Monkey Island"
player in the world, and
also the only one I knew.
But I was just being
greatly entertained.
And I kept coming
back into his room
to watch more and more of
his gameplay on the few games
that he had bought
with his pocket money.
So we were, if you
think about it,
our own little gaming community,
even though quite isolated.
Now, also on the game
development side,
the industry back then
was quite isolated.
So developers and
publishers often
had no clue what was
going to happen the day
of the release of their game.
And players wouldn't
really know what
they were going to
see until they really
bought the game, unless they had
maybe read something about it
in a game specific magazine or
heard about it from friends,
but that was pretty much it.
Now the future of gaming as
I had imagined it back then,
where I could just watch
any game I could think of,
is already happening today.
And funnily enough,
I find myself
working at the very core of it.
With YouTube, we are surfacing
all of these little gaming
communities and bring them
together without limitations.
So you see, while it was really
great watching my brother play,
I could have never imagine
a world where I could just
choose between different
types of personalities
to be entertained
by and seamlessly
switch between games, and
even get recommendations
to discover new games
based on my preferences.
And anyone can do all of
that today on YouTube.
YouTube has really reshaped
the video game landscape
over the past decade.
And to fully
understand how, it's
important to look at
the incredible amount
of innovative and
creative talent
that we have on the
platform, who are often
at the tip of the spear when it
comes to creating new formats,
inspiring trends,
and establishing
audience-building strategies.
Creativity has gone way
beyond just gameplay.
So today on YouTube,
you can find everything
from the most engaging and
entertaining let's play video
to 360 degrees
animations of games,
to acapella songs of
your favorite game
soundtrack to animated
series, to even baking
videos of your favorite
game character as a muffin.
So people find themselves
more interested and curious
about gaming content
than ever before.
And the community is constantly
diversifying, in which gamers
are not only players anymore.
And every month, people
watch billions of hours
of gaming content on YouTube.
So gaming on YouTube has grown
so strongly that last year
in the summer we
took a step further
and we launched YouTube
Gaming, providing a dedicated
home for users to get connected
to the games, players,
and culture that matter to
them with videos, Livestreams,
and actually the biggest
community of gamers on the web,
all in one place.
So if you haven't seen
the YouTube Gaming app,
I highly encourage you to
download it to your phone.
Or if you are on
desktop, you can access
by visiting Gaming.YouTube.com.
Now gaming videos have
gained a lot of traction
over the past decade,
to the point where
YouTubers and their
videos are playing
a crucial role in the economics
of the gaming industry.
Creator's videos are one of
the major factors influencing
which games get more
exposure and find success.
So we've seen an incredible
amount of movement
on the developer
and publisher side.
One example of this is "Surgeon
Simulator," an indie game
by Bossa Studios.
Now this is a story
from back in 2013,
and a thumbnail from
a PewDiePie video.
PewDiePie is actually
our biggest YouTuber
on the platform by subscribers.
He uploads mostly gaming
videos, and to date his channel
has reached more than
44 million subscribers.
And to date, he has reached
more than 12 billion views
on his videos.
So I reached out to
Felix, PewDiePie,
to get approval to use this
image in my presentation.
And his only comment to
it was, oh my god Ina,
what an ancient image.
So considering three
years as ancient,
you get a sense of how fast
the industry is moving here.
"Surgeon Simulator" is a game
by Bossa Studios, an indie game
developer in London.
And so, back in 2013
they uploaded this game
to their game jam site without
really having any expectations.
Then Felix, also
known as PewDiePie,
found the game, loved
it, and he decided
to make a video about it.
Shortly after he
uploaded the video,
the game jam site
crashed, because there
was an overload of PewDiePie
fans accessing the site
to download the game.
And to make things
worse, other YouTubers
followed and created videos
about "Surgeon Simulator,"
which really
skyrocketed the game.
And to put it in
Bossa Studios' words,
the traction in the
first week was insane.
This exposure and momentum
has led to "Surgeon Simulator"
becoming the fastest ever
Greenlit game on Steam.
And they now find themselves
with an established IP
that has sold over 3
million units across five
different platforms.
Way to go for an indie game.
And over time, Bossa Studios
has become really involved
with the YouTube
community, to a point where
in a later version of their
game, the alien version,
they named the organs after
some of their biggest YouTube
supporters.
I know that's very
flattering, but that's
kind of just the fun of YouTube.
Another great example of how
they work with the YouTube
community is from their game
"I Am Bread." "I Am Bread" is
a very fun action adventure
simulation game where
the player is in control
of a slice of bread
and the ultimate goal is
to get the bread toasted.
It turns out there was
a bug in the game, which
made the bread float
around in zero gravity.
And of course, YouTubers
discovered that bug
and had a lot of fun with it.
The YouTube community
actually loved that bug
so much that there were
hundreds of videos produced
around the floating bread.
It really became a thing.
So instead of fixing
the bug, Bossa Studios
really heard the community.
They built the zero
gravity mode into the game
and released it
as a free update.
So today, you can
find many, many fun
let's plays on YouTube
around this space bread.
So guess what?
Not only indie game
developers are working
with the YouTube community.
GTA is a very popular
game on YouTube.
YouTubers just love
recording their gameplay,
and it's an amazing game
to develop storytelling.
So Rockstar, the
publisher of GTA,
wanted to further
fuel that creativity
and enable creators to share
more of their experiences
in an entirely new way.
So they integrated the
Rockstar editor into GTA V.
It's a feature built within the
game that lets players record,
edit, and ultimately
share highlight
moments from their gameplay
using different camera angles,
filters, audio, and so on.
Players can record
gameplay footage
with only the press of a
single button within the game.
There is even a
director mode where
you can stage your own scenes
and create custom moments.
Players can choose from
different story mode
characters.
They can choose location, time,
day, and even the weather.
When done editing, they can
export directly to YouTube,
and we've seen some amazing
results coming through.
We see more collaboration
between developers, YouTube
creators, and the
community than ever before,
and it's very exciting.
Going back to
PewDiePie, he recently
released his own
game, "PewDiePie,
Legend of the Brofist,"
in conjunction
with Outerminds, a video
game development company.
Now in the process of
developing the game,
he constantly worked with
his fans and his community
and got their input.
He shared sneak peeks of
levels and walkthroughs,
and they could
give their feedback
through YouTube comments.
They also had a say on
which other YouTubers
should be included in
the game as characters.
And the community even voted
on the name of the game.
The feedback from
the community was so
mind blowing that the game
became number one in the app
charts right after launch.
But we also see
developers taking a stab
at becoming content
creators themselves,
and quite successfully so.
Miniclip, for example,
has done a tremendous job
on their main official
channel, Agar.io.
They are not only
collaborating with YouTubers
and curating community
content, they also
host regular Livestreams,
bringing in the community
manager and feature
guest players
on the official channel.
So this very inclusive
and very consistent
content strategy has led to
the Miniclip Agar.io channel
reach over 1 million subscribers
within only six months
of launch, which is
quite impressive.
What's great about producing
your own official content
is that you can then link
directly from the YouTube watch
page to your game through
what we call cards.
Cards are clickable
from any device,
and can either link to
your official website,
or in the case of a mobile game
directly to the Google Play
Store and drive
downloads of the game.
Additionally, the game
pages on YouTube Gaming
automatically pull together
all the great content
that is being produced around
your game into one place.
So that's actually a
great place for you
as a developer to discover all
the creative talent out there
that's already creating videos
and Livestreams around your IP
and get in touch.
If you've released
a game, I highly
recommend you to check
out your own game
page on YouTube Gaming.
And I've also included
a link in our--
into our space for
this session, and Noah
will explain a little bit
about what that is again,
on how you can provide us with
information around your game
for these pages.
Or you could just Google
provide YouTube with game data
and you will find that link.
And speaking of more product
innovations, let's talk mobile.
Now we've looked
at mobile gaming
and we just see
skyrocketing growth.
Looking at those numbers,
it was very clear to us
that we not only wanted to
make it an awesome experience
to watch people play
from a mobile phone,
but also to share your
own mobile gameplay
and broadcast it to the world.
Now Ben has already told
you about the amazing stuff
you can do around
integrations within your game,
but we want to also be
inclusive of any type of game.
So part of our update to
the YouTube Gaming app,
as well as to Google Play
Games, as Ben mentioned earlier,
was mobile capture.
Mobile capture on YouTube
Gaming is drop dead simple.
You can select any
game on your phone,
and just tap the record
button and start capturing.
You could choose to add video
of yourself, sound via the mic.
And adding to the
fun of it, you can
Livestream all of that gameplay
directly to your channel
on YouTube already today.
So really your limit to your
mobile gameplay recording
is only your
phone's battery now.
And speaking of
Livestreaming, we're
building up amazing
features on that front.
As I said earlier, we
see constant innovation
around formats on YouTube.
And more and more
creators are now
connecting to their
fans real-time through
Livestreaming.
Also, developers
and publishers often
use Livestreams to
make announcements,
to host tournaments, to
host community streams
around their launches, and
really engage with their fans
through live chat.
Life is becoming an ever
immersive experience.
And we even recently announced
360 degrees Livestreaming.
It's a very exciting era to be
in today in the games industry.
And there are so
many cool products
available to the people
who love and make games.
In the past 15 minutes
or so, I was only
able to give you a
glimpse into this world,
and there are so many
more inspirational stories
from games that have
become really big
and known through the power
of the YouTube community.
The discovery of games
has really changed,
and you don't need
to spend millions
of dollars of marketing budget
anymore to get exposure.
So I highly encourage you
to play an active role
in our community by embracing
the content that's out there,
or creating your own, by really
listening to the community's
feedback, maybe even including
them in the development
of your game.
It all really boils down
to making great games,
and to the combined passion
that we share for games.
And with that, I want to
hand it back over to Noah.
[APPLAUSE]
NOAH FALSTEIN: Thank
you Ina, thank you Ben,
and thank you everyone.
I hope this has been
intriguing, inspiring.
I hope you can see
some ways you can use
these services in your games.
Please go out there and
make some great games
with our technology,
and let us know
what you've done so we can
show you up here next year.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]